hey guys hi you're with Eric who's going
to show me this special darksome vendor
for for noobs like me who are still far
far away from getting to this point in
the game yeah so it turns out there is
another Phoenix gear Phoenix like bender
she takes Phoenix credits rather and
she's in the dark zone I think it's a
she
hopefully I'm not wrong we'll find out
but it's over here in the top part of
the dark zone it's all the way at the
top so the the premise though is that
you have to be level 50 though in the
dark zone yeah in the dark zone dark
zone level 50 otherwise you're not gonna
be able to buy anything from her so it's
kind of useless in a way but we'll make
our way over there so you can kind of
see the stuff that she has like I said
her like on another video that we did I
got the tenebrae blueprint from her
which was really cool but she also you
know sells armor weapons and other
blueprints so we'll check that out right
now oh I was gonna say what is Phoenix
bucks can you explain exactly what those
are cuz like someone in the game like me
I'm not even at a point where I have a
Phoenix watched I guess I do have some
Phoenix bucks I got up like as a reward
so Phoenix credits are another type of
currency that you have in the game it's
like pretty much like endgame currency
you use that primarily to buy you know
blueprints so that you can you know make
new high-end weapons as well as for
recalibrating as well as where we crawl
sorry as well as for recalibrating
high-end gear so it's definitely
important to get those currently the
only ways to really get those are
getting them off named bosses in the
dark zone I believe you can get them off
named bosses in the kind of higher-end
areas like the 28-30 where we were just
at yeah and then I also believe you can
get them from your daily missions so
once you hit 30 you're gonna have three
daily missions that pop for you two of
them are relatively easy they're just
like hard mode versions of them which
aren't too bad they're manageable solo
but the challenge mode one is pretty
insane if every mob is elite so it's
like yellow mobs and they just take a
lot of damage and they're 32 so they're
two levels higher than you the shotgun
guy's taking out in like two shotgun
shots or something like that so I would
suggest not going there until you
actually have good gear people are
probably matchmaking thinking they can
just do it you might be able to do it
with enough strategy but it took me an
hour and a half to do my one run on like
Saturday anyways I was right it is a she
here's the dark zone special vendor and
we'll take a look at her gear so she has
a weapon a vector that's not that great
to be honest you can probably make your
own that was better
I bought the spec ops armor it's not bad
it's pretty good it could have had a
better talent but you know you don't
always get to choose when you don't have
high-end stuff so yeah so go level 30
rank 50 yeah so the only thing I guess
that you could buy if you wanted to is
that you can make dark some keys I don't
you should not buy this okay do not
spend 40 credits on this okay this it's
a waste of money you'll get so many keys
from just doing the dark zone yeah she
also has two jackets like I don't I wish
I could see what they look like they're
expensive though that's the one thing
that always bothered me is you can't
always see that stuff
yeah there's no inspect right now
clothing so that's the one thing that
destiny did really well that right now
isn't in the division like I cannot look
at your gear no like you know so that
would be nice to have maybe maybe in a
future update
but yeah so she sells a bunch of
different blueprints and they're like
some of them are pretty good depending
on like what you want I see some people
making the custom m44 marksman rifle so
this is like a sniper and like if you
get really good rolls like it can do
really sick damage I've seen some
streamers you know with the right
support people with them just like
buffing them they get near like 1
million headshot crits which are like
insane ok but yeah this is kind of your
next endgame kind of vendor after the
special gear vendor in the you know in
your main headquarters once you hit 50
dark zone this is probably where you
want to head to there are other vendors
but she she's the one that takes the
Phoenix credits and she has the some of
the good recipes and so you see some of
those guns have I guess the retail ones
associated with them
yeah these are what they're gonna get
yeah these ones are the those are just
those you want a double-barrel shotgun
there you go have a high-end one that
might roll you know what you want might
not so is your way to tell what what
those talents might be or
they're just no way someone shoot yeah
this one's a crapshoot I mean someone
has come out and started putting out you
know some of the weapon talent so you
can kind of research you know what you
can get but it's a total crapshoot you
you
that's replayability right you gotta
grind your butt off some people get
lucky on the first try and those guys
are the worst people and I hate them but
uh you know I'm jealous of course but uh
yeah these are the ones again that take
division Tech so it's a little bit
harder to craft but you know you do find
division tech here and there sometimes
off the dark zone bosses and then in the
tech boxes that are kind of around and I
think once you get a certain tech wing
upgrade it'll make things easier because
they'll they'll kind of show up on the
map but yeah that's kind of a look at
the dark zone special gear vendor you're
like nest next Phoenix credit person I
guess the person you guys spend the
ascent what's the best what's the what's
the best tip you can give someone to get
to rank 50 in dark zone oh man I would
say definitely don't go rogue yeah
because the risk reward just isn't there
in the game right now I would say try to
find an efficient kind of like run which
I've kind of like figured one out maybe
we can do a video on that just like kind
of what what my run is in the in the
lower end dark zone areas actually maybe
I can show it to you on a map I don't
know I generally like in the dark zone
area like basically you want to figure
out like where the bosses are right and
where there's a lot of mobs so I
generally there's a boss like down here
and then I kind of loop around I do this
blockade there's a boss here and then I
try to swing around to this division
tech building try to get division tech
and then I also kill a boss and then
like I loop back around to this
extraction and just go in a circle and
hope that nobody else is doing the same
thing because there are spawn timers I
believe it's like 10 minutes for bosses
yeah and then for you know like the
crates the big dark stone crates I think
they're like to our cool down so like if
you open one
don't even bother for another two hours
it's not gonna be there but definitely
check and you're doing this solo right I
did it's mostly solo I would say I did
it at 80% solo and then there's a
probably a good 20 percent of that time
where I was with the group and I will
tell you this that if you can get a
group it's just way easier
it's way less stressful you know you
don't have to be afraid that if you die
you're gonna lose all your gear because
someone will revive you you know where's
if you're playing solo you're just gonna
die so if you if you have the
opportunity of course don't run around
solo as well if you can if you can fight
it otherwise just play safe smart get
efficient that's really how it is you
know well there you go that's what you
have to look forward to when you get to
level 50 in the dark zone
you